12.500 migranten sind auf einen schlag
obdachlos geworden als letzte woche das
flüchtlingslager moria komplett
niederbrannte
schon kurz nach dem vorfall vermuteten
die behörden dass das feuer mit absicht
gelegt wurde jetzt hat die griechische
polizei tatsächlich fünf personen
festgenommen und eine weitere person die
wird noch gesucht in lesbos ist jetzt
bild-reporter til biermann was weiß man
dann über die mutmaßlichen brandstifter
nenne ich sie jetzt mal die mutmaßlichen
brandstifter sind afghanische
staatsangehörige
es soll sich bei zwei von ihnen
womöglich um unbegleitete minderjährige
handeln die vor kurzem noch so nach nach
der mutmaßlichen brandstiftung nach
thessaloniki aufs festland geflogen
worden war
und wenn man sich bei den menschen im
alten verbrannten moria camp umhört die
sich dort wieder angesiedelt haben
können sie sich das alles nicht erklären
da kursieren gerüchte dass die
griechische polizei selbst gewesen sei
und es ist wohl so dass auch die polizei
in den letzten tagen sehr sehr hart
ermittelt hat ein afghane erzählte mir
wenn man nur mit einem feuerzeug in der
tasche erwischt wurde hätten die beamten
in das feuerzeug an einen gehalten und
ihn so zu sagen weh zu tun und ich hatte
auch vor zwei tagen einmal eine
polizeirazzia miterlebt im lager an der
küstenstraße in dem camp da waren
unvermittelt 40 der gruppe afghanen
ausgeführt wurden von von polizisten in
zivil in diesen dann in einen in eine
ruine geführt wurden und man hat mich
weggeschickt weggeschubst also die
polizei sagt sie abhauen sie ab das
waren offenbar intensiver ermittlungen
die dazu jetzt geführt haben diese
mutmaßlichen brandstifter festnehmen
das hört sich ganz ganz furchtbar an was
was passiert denn jetzt mit diesen mit
den brandstiftern sind die in haft
einfach nur ja die werden jetzt
sicherlich in untersuchungshaft sein und
man muss ihnen das ja auch irgendwie
nachweisen
ich vermute diese eine
hat sich dort gesehen hatte war
wahrscheinlich so etwas das man versucht
hat die leute zu finden die sie
beschuldigen aber das ist jetzt alles
mutmaßungen ja die werden jetzt in haft
sein und dann wird jetzt versuchen den
dass auch diese tat auch nachweisen zu
können
du konntest selber auch mit menschen
sprechen die die verschiedene dinge
gesagt haben auch zur lage jetzt wie sie
leben wie was was waren da die aussagen
ja also es gibt ja das neue camp das
gebaut wurde von der griechischen
regierung dass es mit stacheldraht
umgeben unicef zelt konnte ich kurz
einmal heute rein da kam hoher besuch
aus brüssel der eu ratspräsidentschaft
schell wurde mit einem militärhelikopter
eingeflogen inspizierte dieses lager von
oben und dieses camp und sagte dass
ihnen das dass ihnen die bilder der
obdachlosen obdachlos also noch die
waren ja schon halb obdachlos auch im
alten kämpen mori aber jetzt geht es ihm
noch schlechter dass ihn das sehr
berührt habe und dass die eu jetzt sehr
starken einer lösung suche und dann kam
die nachricht dass 1500 familien und
zwar familien die schon einen
schutzstatus haben 1000 menschen aus
familien nach deutschland kommen könnte
habe ich dann die menschen gefragt was
sie denn von dieser zahl und von diesem
und von diesem von dieser diesem angebot
deutschlands halten und das könnt ihr
euch auch mal gucken 1500 leute so zu
wenig wir wollen dass mehr leute nach
deutschland dürfen
10.000 zb oder 11.000 schließlich nehmen
hier in monja drei von tausend leute
meiner meinung nach ist die aufnahme von
1500 leuten zu gering
das ist sehr sehr gut wir sind schon
seit einem jahr hier auf lesbos
das ist viel zu wenig hier sind 2000
flüchtlinge es gibt viele kinder und
familien die krank sind hier mit jeder
griechenland verlassen
wir wissen die bundesregierung die wir
mehr als 1500 flüchtlinge aufnehmen
nach welchen kriterien werden die dann
ausgewählt die nach deutschland kommen
dürfen
ja es ist so dass es eben familien sein
werden und zwar familien die auch schon
einen sogenannten schutzstatus haben
also schon ein interview hatten ein asyl
interview das nicht negativ verlaufen
ist für sie also den bescheinigt wurde
dass sie nicht einfach in ihre heimat
zurück können und das sind ja so wie ich
das in den interviews geführt haben mit
den menschen die allerwenigsten dort
allermeisten hatten entweder noch gar
kein interview hatten vielleicht jetzt
nächsten monat eins gehabt aber durch
den brand ist es alles verschoben worden
oder sie wurden auch schon ihr interview
wurde auch schon negativ bescheinigt und
wichtig ist halt das sagte mir heute die
un hcr sprecherin
damit will man offenbar versuchen auch
die leute ins neue camp zu kriegen wir
überhaupt eine chance haben will ausland
aus europäische festland zu kommen wäre
eine chance haben will einen
schutzstatus bekommt der muss ins neue
camp gehen denn dort wird man
registriert und nur dort kann es weiter
gehen und eine letzte frage wird ja
gerade ein neues lager aufgebaut viele
flüchtlinge wollen da aber gar nicht hin
wieso ja es ist so dass unter den
flüchtlingen und migranten auch gerüchte
kursieren die stimmen nicht so wie das
handy wird einem abgenommen der goethe
wird einmal abgenommen die schnürsenkel
werden einem abgenommen es gehören es
kursieren allerdings auch die gerüchte
dass man wenn man
hat erstmal drin ist nicht wieder
rauskommt und das stimmt so halb denn
tatsächlich ist es so dass bestätigte
mir auch die un hat zuerst sprecherin
erstmal ist es nicht geplant dass die
menschen die in dieses neue lager
reingehen in denen jetzt diese neuen
weißen zelte stehen dass sie dann
einfach immer rein und rausgehen können
wie sie wollen und das schreckt viele ab
denn sie haben angst dann wie in einem
gefängnis zu leben
keine sorgen mehr machen zu können die
meisten kriegen ja im monat 75 euro von
hilfsorganisationen mit denen sie auch
reis kaufen können bedarf es mittel um
irgendwie über die runden zu kommen und
viele haben angst dort einfach
eingeschlossen zu werden
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren